o iPhone wallpaper plena Ponte Estaiada
leite eu vou ver ele é
e eu quero contar a você a dor que eu
senti quando eu vendi aquilo que eu
criei e mais todos os desafios ao longo
desse processo mas antes eu quero trazer
um pouco da minha história eu desde
pequeno era tido pelos meus amigos como
o rato do laboratório eu saía da escola
com as minhas irmãs nós íamos ao
laboratório dos meus pais em Joinville
Santa Catarina e quando nós chegávamos
no laboratório eu não conseguia ficar
parado esperando pelos dois para irmos a
casa em para casa para o almoço e aí eu
ficava andando dentro do laboratório me
conectando com os profissionais e
buscando reativos e tubos de ensaio que
laboratório já não usava mais em casa
nós tínhamos 3 garagens e dois carros e
na terceira garagem de casa eu acabei
criando com as minhas irmãs e com alguns
amigos
o laboratório e foi de Sininho
laboratório que eu acabei criando um
grande sonho de criar um laboratório
diferente daquele que muitas vezes eu
enxergava sentia e escutava no dia-a-dia
no cotidiano da minha família eu tive a
oportunidade de fazer farmácia
bioquímica me graduar mas ao longo de
toda minha trajetória enquanto
adolescente eu passava muitas das minhas
férias estagiando no laboratório eu
tenho uma conexão muito grande com a
área da Medicina Laboratorial e uma
paixão por essa ciência também então eu
abri a mente acreditava muito que o meu
futuro seria um futuro na saúde e por
que não obviamente nas análises clínicas
eu comecei trabalhando no laboratório
dos Pais ouvindo do meu pai sobre a
importância da gestão com a minha mãe
muito
o fim do escutando todos os direcionais
do atendimento da experiência para com
paciente para com o cliente e nesta ou
nessas inspirações eu acabei criando o
ensejo à vontade de fazer administração
de empresas me graduei e durante a
faculdade eu tive grandes oportunidades
de interagir com os professores e por
intermédio dos Desafios do laboratório
dos pais eu chegava montar projetos
criavam os programas dentro do
laboratório e eu fui me desenvolvimento
mais uma das questões que me faltavam
naquela época quando eu estava iniciando
o meu formato de gestor era eu ter
conexão com jovens empresários jovens
empreendedores E aí eu fui em busca por
intermédio do associativismo da criação
da Montagem porque não de um grupo de
um talento jovens empreendedores que
pudessem obviamente numa conexão de
networking de troca de benchmark buscar
obviamente os seus desenvolvimento e com
isso eu tive oportunidade de me inspirar
Ainda mais quando eu dentro do
laboratório dos pais com a minha irmã a
Monique Minha ex sócia a criarmos no ano
de 2003 um plano de negócio a criação de
um laboratório que num primeiro momento
competiria com o laboratório dos Pais
apenas no segmento apenas no negócio
porém com outros expertises e moscando
entregar hipersegmentação ao cliente um
trabalho intra-empreendedor um trabalho
de conexão e para atender a outras
cidades e foi isso que nós fizemos nós
fizemos um plano de negócios que não foi
aprovado fizemos um segundo no ano de
2004 que aí sim foi aprovado
e nós naquele naquela ocasião na
apresentação do plano inclusive os dois
irmãos subiram num banquinho meio que
numa brincadeira para que nós ficássemos
mais altos e tivéssemos Olha nós temos
aqui uma grande ideia e aí a gente
mostrou nesse plano de negócios esse
laboratório desenhado de uma forma
diferente com esse trabalho que olhava
para os públicos para os segmentos como
crianças Lembrando que o produto de uma
Pretória de análises clínicas é uma
picada que dói é um laudo que pode doer
a criança que tem medo receio da agulha
da seringa então Nós criamos um primeiro
momento uma uma ideia junto à equipe
intraempreendedora do laboratório
laboratório uma casa de brinquedos é que
tivesse obviamente até no nome todo
mundo ensejo infantil e assim nós
começamos o trabalho né da segmentação
e depois nós olhávamos por intermédio
das Mega tendências para as mulheres e
queremos um cenário uma unidade
específica e especializada no
atendimento às mulheres onde homens não
entram crianças não entram onde a mulher
é atendida por mulheres foco e
direcionamento uma outra veia
empreendedora em um trabalho de peça
alimentação de clientes foi o nosso
laboratório Popular nós entregamos
qualidade deste nosso laboratório com um
preço extremamente competitivo e nós
tínhamos um viés de olhar é para outras
cidades como eu tinha falado né E
acabamos entrando em outras cidades que
não só Joinville e na venda depois
altamente de 12 anos da criação Nós já
estávamos em sete cidades do Estado de
Santa Catarina com todo esse trabalho de
olhar para a comunidade olhar para o
médico olhar para a secretária olhar
para os estudantes de saúde
e para fornecedores visitantes e olhar
para o cliente de uma forma diferente e
uma cidade onde nasci eu fui tido eu
recebi um Título de Cidadão benemérito
da cidade então contemplando Aí sim um
título bastante importante quer dizer
nessa trajetória de vida num belo dia no
ano de 2015 eu acabei acordando e eu
tive um grande Insight né Nós estamos
criando esse laboratório com essa
dinâmica empresa superavitária ficando
bastante grande e eu pensei
fala sobre a sucessão eu lembro nosso
batom área nós éramos apenas uma
Pretória de análises clínicas nós não
tínhamos imagem nós não tínhamos vacina
nós não temos anatomia patológica e a
gente olhava para fora nos mercados mais
desenvolvidos e a gente percebe que por
intermédio de uma parada né do conceito
do ano Stop Shop separa e resolve as
suas necessidades da saúde e nós não
tínhamos isso nós também olhávamos para
o cenário Brasil olhávamos para economia
política enxergávamos desafios olhávamos
para o Estado de Santa Catarina e vimos
uma oportunidade uma janela aberta ainda
de um estado que não tinha recebido
nenhuma aquisição fusão na área da
Medicina Laboratorial e mais a mãe que
eu nós acreditávamos muito na nossa
competência de realização nós
acreditávamos literalmente nessa atitude
e nas habilidades Que nós tínhamos
naquele momento então no ano de 2015 a
gente resolve
o cartório e apenas uma das coisas que a
gente deixou claro para nós aqui nós não
comunicar íamos mas todo um trabalho que
nós estávamos fazendo que eu acabei
apresentando aqui para vocês nós
acreditávamos nessa venda na
possibilidade de grandes Laboratórios
virem Até nós para nos comprarem
profissionalmente o grande sonho tava
lançado a venda da empresa consenso
entre os dois irmãos estava feito mas
pessoalmente eu aos 40 anos eu queria
ser pai entrei com meu companheiro com o
Régis na fila do processo de adoção e
nós não esperávamos que ao longo de todo
o processo à espera poderia ser de até
10 anos À Espera de um filho de um
menino eu com 39 para 40 anos
acreditando que com quarenta eu
receberia a criança e praticamente um
balde de água gelada veio até nós por
intermédio de uma informação dizendo
Olha é possivelmente
há dez anos vocês receberão esta criança
então nós tínhamos um sonho da venda o
sonho da criança nós estávamos na fila a
negociação da venda ela começou a
acontecer porque os grandes Laboratórios
começaram sim a nos procurar E aí minha
gata felicidade um outro laboratório
muito grande no país nos procurou para
que o seu presidente o seu ciúme fizesse
um benchmarking conosco e vs aprender
com a Monique comigo Lembrando que o
laboratório que nós estávamos inserido
era um laboratório que tava ganhando
vários prêmios nacionais e o palestrante
internacionalmente a gente de uma certa
maneira mostrando muita consistência nos
congressos brasileiros e nos cursos e
palestras que eu estava criando na
dinâmica de troca Nossa recebendo muitas
visitas aqui no Estado de Santa Catarina
para conhecer no nosso modelo de negócio
quer dizer Nós chamávamos atenção e esse
grande laboratório chegou até nós
o presidente veio de uma forma muito
humilde muito simples com um discurso
adorável E ele nos convenceu de que
aquele laboratório tinha os valores que
nós também valorizava vamos aquelas
características que lá ele estava
desenhando era aquilo que nós aqui
tínhamos como DNA e ali criou-se uma
conexão e a gente acabou escolhendo dos
cinco ou das cinco propostas que nós
tínhamos o direcional foi para esse
laboratório deste presidente que veio
aprender que venha interagir e criar
essa dinâmica da troca conosco E no meio
desta loucura da negociação da venda nós
recebemos por intermédio da Vara da
Infância e da família nós recebemos uma
ligação dizendo o filho de vocês chegou
e eu estava praticamente com a idade ali
os meus 41 com a idade do sonho de
receber essa criança em casa
e agora eu quero contar para vocês do
dia dez de outubro de dois mil e
dezessete o dia em que nós assinamos os
contratos da venda do negócio e a grande
dor veio no momento em que eu fui ao
aeroporto da cidade buscar este
presidente que tinha de uma certa
maneira vindo aprender conosco e ele se
declarou também fã de todo o nosso
trabalho e eu de longe chegando eu
estava dirigindo e me aproximando do
aeroporto da cidade um dia lindo eu vi o
avião descendo e a minha dor dentro do
carro começou a praticamente me
estremecer naquele momento eu tava
realmente e sentia que eu estava
entregando um dos nossos Grandes
projetos de vida nos dias de hoje eu
estou então conectado na estou dentro
desta empresa trabalhando nessa empresa
O que é a maior empresa de Medicina
Diagnóstica fim da América Latina e ao
mesmo tempo Nesse quesito pessoal a
gente nós estamos desenvolvendo Hotel
essa criança fantástica maravilhosa eu
sonhei eu acreditei eu fiz acontecer
e da garagem ao sonho de ter um
laboratório de análises clínicas
inovador e do Laboratório A gestão do
cliente na maior empresa de Diagnósticos
clínicos da América Latina agora eu
trago a você uma pergunta que tal Criar
o seu negócio ou que tal continuar a
desenvolver o seu negócio que tava
acreditar trabalhar muito transformar
este negócio em algo sustentável E por
que não prepará-lo para venda